[Music]
i've been really excited about giving
this
uh topic i've had it on my brain for
several months now
and i'm glad to get out some of this
information
i i just want to praise everyone that
showed up for this um the top
the title uh that includes uh best
practices for administering our student
production
is not a very sexy title um so i'm
really glad that people showed up for
the talk
i do have a lot of uh things topics to
go through i'll try to go through
quickly
uh give you an overview of a number of
different topics i think
are important before jumping into the
demos so i work in solutions engineering
and at solutions engineering uh that our
team helps
you integrate our studio products into
your system um so
things that involve integration are
things like authentication
security servers cloud architectures
databases spark tensorflow kubernetes
all these things that surround your our
environment these are the things that we
get really excited about
we have a great team you might have seen
us around uh the team members are sean
edgar cole andre james kelly
chris and alex and uh we hang out in a
variety of places uh the best place to
find us is in community
and we hope that you'll go to community
and interact with us there
we have a github page and our own
website
and then we frequently contribute to the
support and docs websites
this webinar is really designed for the
r admin uh sometimes i call
the r admin a data scientist who wants
to do more um they want to do things
like
pipelines and installations scaling and
building these platforms
um if that describes you welcome here in
the right place
um there are evangelists people who are
trying to get
our studio and are more uh widely
adopted
in their organizations it ops of course
we're always happy to have it ops on
board
and anyone who wants to try r studio
professional products if you don't know
anything about professional products and
this is your first time
here um this is a great way to get
introduced to professional products
we're going to walk actually walk
through all of them
so our studio empowers individuals to be
productive
with data science but we believe in
things like uh
well we're strong believers in open
source and reproducible research
and uh we believe in things like apis
and interoperability
we want to have our work be you know
really usable with clear documentation
we believe in inclusivity and collective
success
we really want all of the work that we
do to have lasting value
so we take a long-term approach here at
our studio
we build open source and professional
software for data science
our open source software is used in
almost every organization that uses
r when organizations benefit from open
source software
we think they have an obligation to
reinvest in the community that provided
it
organizations can contribute to our open
source software in part by purchasing
our professional products but our
business does not rely
on altruism our professional features
include important things that
customers want like security
authentication load balancing support
many other things
and these are the products that we sell
uh rca server pro our studio connect
in our studio package manager and then
the money that we make from these
professional products funds our open
source software
most of the money that we earn actually
goes into open source software
what's the relationship between r and r
studio well we don't own our we don't
package it we don't distribute it
the our core team has 20 members and
zero of them are from our studio
we like to say our studio sits on top of
our so you standardize on our first
and then install our profit products
second we assume that you have chosen to
invest in r in fact last year
i gave a webinar called professional r
tooling and integration where i talked
about
legitimacy competencies and adoption so
legitimacy is about recognizing
r as an analytic standard and
competencies are about understanding of
managing
our tooling and adoption is about
relying on integrated r
based solutions so today we're going to
be talking
about competencies and where those
competencies come from how do you learn
about r this is a big problem actually
with a lot of our customers
they don't know how to do uh to
administer
our products in their organization and
there's a couple of reasons why
first of all r is relatively unknown in
most organizations there's no single
place to get all the information you
need
it's really hard to see the forest
through the trees there's a lot of
pieces involved
a lot of things are changing very
quickly so we see a lot of our customers
going through a lot of trial and error
some of those include organizational
hurdles for example the i.t department
might be completely separate from the
data science department and
maybe the communication or the support
isn't there
or there might be resource limitations
like maybe there's uh
the funding for the head count is
separate from the funding for
the the servers or the infrastructure
and they're not able
and people aren't able to get the
servers that they need
so today i want to share some best
practices for managing our studio in
production
i want to share the product requirements
go over some tips
and give you a path for getting started
my goal is to give you a big picture
view
of what success looks like assuming
you're using our products
so i want to share five best practices
for administering
our studio in production
number one keep your system up to date
so you're going to want modern tools for
your data science platform
that means modern operating systems and
modern browsers you'll be using the
cutting edge tools you'll be doing
cutting edge analysis you'll be
hiring people with very um important
skills and you're going to want
modern tools for all of those things
you'll need a c
plus 11 compiler um so that you can
build the r packages
on your system and you'll want to think
about your internet access and that's
because all of your packages are coming
from the that are probably coming from
the internet if you don't have internet
access
in your server environment a lot of
organizations don't then it's very
important that you talk to our studio
because all of our products are designed
to run
in an offline mode
number two support multiple versions of
r
why do you want to support multiple
versions of r well because you want to
be able to manage
upgrades you want to be able to test
code on a variety of our versions and
you want to support
projects that depend on various versions
of all r
all of our all of our products support
multiple versions
of r we recommend that you upgrade at
least yearly
and that use a modern version of r so
3.1 or greater
and then finally we this is very
important that we recommend that you
build r from source
building r from source allows you to
install multiple versions of r
side by side it's not hard to do it
follows the standard config
make make install path most
organizations have a process
for building software from source
already
in place and we have instructions for
how to do that
number three organize your r packages
so our packages rule the nest uh
packages will drive your r
version your linux dependencies and even
your operating system
data scientists will want to access
their most beloved packages
so say you have a data scientist who
wants like the most recent
you know modeling package and they try
to install it and it fails
because it needs a new version of r so
you want to upgrade that version of r
and then you find that you're going to
need some linux binaries but those linux
binaries aren't really supported by your
operating system so suddenly you're
upgrading your whole operating system to
support that package of r
that is not an unrealistic scenario
that's one reason we say keep your
platform modern and up to date
so it turns out that modern that
managing packages for a single user is
quite easy like you do on your desktop
but managing packages for an entire
platform is really hard
we should know our studio knows a lot
about managing packages
so we created a package manager it's
called the rstudio package manager
and it solves several problems one
problem is when your environment is
disconnected from the internet or
you're in an air-gapped environment you
need a way to get packages
into that environment and package
manager can help with that another one
is being able to serve consistent
environments to docker containers
so if your docker container is running
one environment it's probably not the
same environment that you're building on
but the package manager can help
standardize those environments um you
there's also security control for um
package repositories a lot of
organizations like to
curate the packages that that gets
delivered to their
organization and then also package
manager helps with
sharing internal packages so since
package
manager is brand new i thought i'd run
through a quick demo of how it works
this is the rstudio package manager and
it has this nice ui
so people can log in and
see all the packages that are available
to them and in this case
these are my packages this is my
description i can see
like how often my packages are being
updated here
so in this case these uh packages were
updated
uh on march 17th and 179 packages were
added
159 packages were archived you can see
the alpha sim r
package here was archived in version .9
because it was upgraded to version 0.10
now all the packages in this snapshot
are indexed with this
identifier 1303. if i want to see all of
the
in all of the snapshots i can look at
this calendar function
and see uh the history of when my
packages were updated
so my most recent version was march 17th
and here
i can see this is the specific snapshot
1303
that indexes that specific set of
packages
i can copy that url and i can paste it
into my ide
and that means that everything that all
the packages i pull from then on in that
ide
are going to pull from a very specific
set of packages
then i can take that uh
that uh url the
package repository location and put that
in my docker container
when i spin up your container and it
will pull the same packages i use for
my analysis we call this a shared
baseline so that everyone is going to be
using the same
packages that are pegged to this
checkpoint
in addition to uh these in the indexing
the packages
i can also organize multiple
repositories so here you see i have a
repository that consists
just of validated uh packages for my
group
this repository has packages that were
contributed internally but from my
organization and this
repository has packages that are being
pulled down from github
so uh what this does is what like
package manager allows me to do is pull
down
packages from github and compile them or
build them
locally so that i can have the most
up-to-date packages
i can also see the usage stats
for my packages which is nice i can see
which packages are being downloaded
which licenses are being used
so package manager is really valuable to
organizations who are standardizing on r
we hope you'll give that a consideration
we'll be
coming back and visiting that in a
little bit
all right so number number four
use root privileges so the group
in your organization that installs
configures and manages r in our studio
will need root privileges
so our studio installs our studio
installs require root privileges
and our studio products also
run as root our studio server pro runs
as the root user in order to create a
new r session on behalf of its users
and rstudio connect runs as a root user
in order to isolate applications and
processes
i will also add that system-wide
installations of
r on linux typic oftentimes involve root
as well
so this is very important that the
people that have the permissions
in your system to install are are able
to under are able
to do so effectively so that means if
that person is you
then you need to know how to install the
products
and the software sufficiently
on that system if that person is someone
else then you need to help that
person understand what this process
involves that means
installing r the r packages and the
products
so the root user privileges you may or
may not have that but whoever does have
that needs to
have that understanding of what it means
to support a platform
on r okay and the last one
five is securely manage your users
there's two types of users there's our
programmers and there's end users and
there are programmers uh will need
access to our file shares databases and
probably many other sensitive systems
our prior our processes for our
programmers
run as the user under a local account so
users need local accounts on the system
to be
run making running these types of
analyses end users on the other hand
are people that may or may not know are
and just consume apps and reports
for these the our processes typically
run under a service account
and if you look at our two products
you'll see that our studio server pro
is serving our programmers and our
studio connect
is serving end users the way you
configure
our studio or our programmers and end
users
are probably going to be slightly
different experiences
um and those hooking up those systems
will be slightly different as well
so how do you hook those up well that's
where authentication comes in
your organization probably has strong
opinions on how to authenticate users
this space is only getting more
fragmented not less
so if you look at like a lot of on-prem
solutions today we'll have like ldap
active directory um and then a lot of
the web
um technologies uh the cloud
technologies
have things like octa duo and auth and
ping and shibboleth
and many many more so we
want to support as many systems as
possible to work with your
authentication system and we're working
hard to do that
and then you will go ahead and configure
our studio
with those whatever authentication
system that
your organization have has now if our
uh products don't support your
particular authentication system
then we recommend using proxied auth in
proxied auth
users don't log in through our studio
they actually log through a proxy that
you set up
and all this is in in the guides the
supported auth methods for our studio
server pro or pam
pretty much um and rcu connect the
supported auth methods are typically
ldap active directory
or pam and uh and saml which is coming
up uh soon so we're working on
on saml uh finally i want to mention
kerberos which is an authentication it's
access control but use kerberos to
connect to databases
and those are supported by our drivers
our professional drivers allow you to
connect to databases using odbc
all right so in summary uh here's
my recommendations number one keep your
operating systems and browsers up to
date
number two plan to support multiple
versions of r by building
r from source number three organize your
r packages for reliability and
consistency
number four use root privileges to
install and run our studio products
and number five securely manage your our
programmers
and end users so if you stay to these
five things that you
architect and execute your our platform
you'll have a lot more success and
there's some information
uh so we've written up some information
about how to do this online as well
you come to this page you can see we've
got
professional product requirements and i
go through all the professional product
requirements here
all right so now that we have like a
path for success what does it look like
to get started
so the first thing is to get the right
tools our studio makes
tools that you put together there are
many ways to assemble our tools but it's
going to be up to you to decide how to
put them together
your configuration depends on what data
science means to your organization
our goal is to make it as easy to
install and configure all of our
products
so your solutions might look like a data
science lab where all your data
scientists
work together maybe you're building
applications
in a dev test prod framework that you're
trying to orchestrate
and deliver to end users you could be on
premises or on a cloud or a hybrid cloud
you could have a single server or multi
departmental deployments depending on
how large your organization is no matter
what you're doing i
typically recommend thinking about a
crawl walk run strategy
where you think about like what the
platform's going to look like long term
and then you start with crawl and walk
i see a lot of organizations doing that
and i think that's a fine
strategy so this is what a setup might
look like
for you uh you might have uh you know
rstudio
might develop uh be for your development
uh platform and will connect to your
projects and your
home file shares your rstudio connect
will be your your publishing
platform and will connect to your uh
your your file share and your metadata
and then your package manager will
support both of these products
and then down below here we have some
databases or data sources that you're
going to
hook up with our professional drivers
now the way the number of servers that
you use and the size of the servers you
use can
is you know wild you know varies across
the board
you can put all three products onto the
same server i would call that a sandbox
and that's fine we do that internally
you can put a different product onto
each server and this is typically what
we recommend is
you know separate the products onto
their own servers we call that a data
science lab you have three servers that
are
working together you can double that for
high availability
if you'd like to make sure that you're
going to have you know a server to fail
over to if there's a problem
and then if you want to extend those out
you know on a clustered approach you can
do that as well
we have some guidelines for hardware
configuration and sizing
and you can look at that and kind of get
started with
the size of your servers
all right so once you have your hardware
set up let's talk about uh recipes for
doing the installation and configuration
recipes are a list of ingredients
that make up your platform they help you
organize and automate your work
and they're probably going to be unique
to your organization
now most recipes will have
a structure that will look like code for
linux
r and r packages then there will be a
small section for
your installation and then the rest of
it will be about your configuration
so if you've installed r properly
installation will be
pretty easy to do the configuration
can be simple or complex
so i went back and pulled out some of my
old recipes
and i want to show you one here this is
actually the recipe that was
i used to build the box that this script
is
actually run running on and you can see
that most of it
is around linux and just getting set up
getting the dependencies
and then i come down here to this
section where i show
multiple versions of r being built from
source
then here's my packages all the packages
i installed in my system library
and then this little section is uh the
install and that's really typical if you
if you sold r properly hopefully our
installs go really easily
and then this last section is the
configuration
and like i said your configuration may
be complex or simple this is a pretty
simple
configuration i just set a few things
around the groups and the the dashboard
and memory limits
and um and then that's it so this is a
really simple
recipe uh something that you can run by
hand
what you really want to do with these
recipes is go ahead and
you know automate them so my colleague
kelly o'brien gave a great talk
at rstudio conf called configuration
management and tools for the r admin
where she
argued for infrastructure as code using
things like
ansible chef puppet co-deploy salt stack
and or
systems like these and what these do is
they organize your recipes so that you
can manage your platform more
effectively and automatically so
i definitely encourage you to have those
conversations with your your team on
how to set that up you need to be very
good at deploying r
and managing upgrades and um you know
helping these
platforms uh scale out and to do that
you might want to buy
or you know procure a sandbox
that allows you to play around with the
configuration scripts so the sandboxes
are great places to learn
and uh if you haven't done this before
it just
uh typically involves reading a lot of
docs and trying things out
it's tax season um and uh
you know playing with uh systems
administration reminds me a little bit
of taxes you just have to read a lot of
really
boring and detailed documents and try
things out
hopefully when you make a mistake in
your sandbox that will be a lot less
forgiving than the irs will be if you
make a mistake in your taxes
but the general idea is uh open up the
docs get familiar with the
with the work and um and try things out
all right so what if you've never used
any of these products
well that's where the rstudio quick
start comes in
so the rstudio quickstart is a virtual
machine that runs on your desktop
and includes all of our professional
products and
includes pre-built assets for you to
explore and demonstrate to others
so the reason we did this was so that
people could experience our studio
professional
products freely and easily and i want to
go ahead and demo
the quick start to you today
this is the quick start page this is the
location
it's fairly easy to find you enter
your your name and email and the
download will take
about 20 minutes to download it's a
fairly large payload if your internet
connection is faster maybe
10 minutes and then you'll need to also
download and install virtualbox and
virtualbox
allows you to run this vm
on your windows or your mac desktops
there's instructions for both we'll just
pull up the appliance
and hit the hit the go button and you
will be good to go so let me
once once that's ready to go you'll
point your browser to localhost 5000
and it will look something like this
well
it won't look like that at all it'll
look like this
there you go so this is our welcome page
and we can take a tour and you can find
out all about
rstudio connect and play around with
that and
a little bit about our studio server pro
as well
so let's go ahead and get started we'll
just log into our studio connect
this is the main ui for rstudio connect
and you can see there's some assets here
that i've
already put in to the tool
and i'm going to go ahead and show you a
couple of those
this is the enterprise ready dashboards
the great thing about this
dashboard is that it runs on shiny
on our studio connect and it connects to
a database that we actually
installed inside of the virtual machine
and these
this is done with d3 i can click this
and
we'll zoom in if i drill down
it'll open up a new tab i drill down
again and open up another new tab
and i can decide who this dashboard is
can uh who gets to see this dashboard so
for example
right now anyone can see it but if i
just want to limit to specific users i
could do that as well
i can also decide how many resources to
give the dashboard now this is in a vm
so the limit the resources are going to
be limited
but if this were on a server i could
increase the number of connections
and serve more users
so this is a shiny application and shiny
applications are really uh
great for interactive analyses sometimes
you need to run things in batch mode
and send snapshots of the the work that
you're doing
and for that type of work you want to
use in our markdown document
so here is another dashboard but it's
written
in our markdown so it might look like uh
it might look like a shiny application
but it's actually not it's actually a
static dashboard
just has a lot of interactive graphics
inside of it and what's cool about this
one is that i can actually
make changes to this dashboard through
parameters
that i've added to my document so our
markdown can be parameterized
so here if i select you know a new new
settings and i do a new window
run up the acceptance rate i can run
this report
and this will update that report with
those settings
when i'm done with that i can i can go
ahead and send out the email
right so i'll go ahead and run this
report while it's running i'll come over
here and look at the email
this email is also inside of the virtual
machine
and you can see it has a star because i
just sent it today
just now and this is what the email
looks like
so it's got some graphics in it it's got
some information
tells me like let me know if you have
any questions and i've attached
my excel document here which allows me
to pull up excel
and look at the data these are the data
in this report
so this is a great way to share your
information
and if you want to distribute your
information you can do that as well
on a schedule i'll hit
the schedule i can go ahead and set the
schedule
and say i want to run this report every
monday tuesday wednesday
go ahead and save that
and i can send myself an email when i'm
done i can send to collaborators
i can decide who else do i want to send
it to and that means
i can send one report to one group and
another
version of this report to another group
on a schedule i don't have to worry
about it
and if i do need if i do have any issues
those are all going to be tracked in the
logs here and i can see the logs
go back to my code i can fix the law the
code
and publish that information here so how
how do i publish information back in
here
let's let's take a quick look i'll come
back
to the welcome page
and notice i have a lot of other
products in here i've got our studio
server pro in here as well
so i'll go ahead and click that
this will deliver
an instance of our studio pro to me and
i have a simple shiny application here
i can run this application in my ide
and you can see that i can play around
with this
and i can publish this to rstudio
connect
oh it doesn't like it let me go ahead
and create a new one
file new file shiny web app
new app
run that
i'll publish this to rstudio
connect
and while it's publishing what it does
is it goes back and it
kind of describes all the environment
and then sends that information over to
our studio connects we can rebuild the
environment
along with all the code and data assets
and there we have it in our studio
connect and
again i can decide who i want to share
this with
i can even open this in its own window
and then that url will you know work
with anyone that's
on my machine which is me i'm the only
one on my machine um
but uh this is how you would share a
shiny application on a server
okay now in addition to the shiny
applications and there are markdown
documents that you can publish
you can also publish uh apis
and apis are basically
systems for allowing you know one
computer to talk to another computer
and in this case this is the plumber api
and that means that
it's which uses rest and
that means i can call my api through a
rest call a respace call like
through a browser so i will show you
what this looks like if i go ahead and
try out this
api and i say give me the stock ticker
for facebook
right it gives me all the information
for facebook and it gives me
this url that i can use
to query the api
so there's facebook if i do microsoft
create api and pull up microsoft now
apis are extremely helpful for the
handoff problem if you
need to hand off your r analyses to
someone else
then um apis are a great way to do that
because
all you have to specify to the the other
group or the other system
is the api itself you don't have to say
anything about r
so you can keep r running on our studio
connect and use that to serve
information
to other systems it's really nice
they're easy to code
they're easy to deploy
okay um great so let's come back
to the our presentation here
so in summary oh wait wait hold on i
think i went too fast
i wanted to show a few more things on
the um our studio quick start
so in addition to our studio server pro
our student connect
we also have the package manager which
i've showed
which i've shown you already and you can
see how this has a curated
package list you can also
come in here and take a look at the
resource guide which will give you an
overview of
getting started and learning about our
products
there's this great article here under
tips for planning your evaluation
that talks about how to explore the
value
of the products proving the process
works and testing
the configuration so these are all great
for getting started
if you have any questions or need any
help
you can get that here at the r studio
community forums
under the help section so that's
going to be this group right um and our
team is all over this
the person that put most of this
together was cole art um
this is cole here and uh he would love
to hear from you
i would definitely love to make the
products better so if you end up using
quickstart and you find that you have an
issue please reach out to him
some of our most common issues are
collected in this frequently asked
questions section
on our site
most of the problems so far have been
around virtualbox more than
around the quick start so this will be
useful
and then if you want to get
more technical information you can come
here to the official documentation
so we hope that you'll use the the quick
start
try it out get a feel for it it actually
comes in handy for
many things that i do personally so i
find
i get a lot of benefit out of this we
hope that you'll
get a chance to try it out and
experience some of our products
and we hope that it's an easy and a good
experience for you all right
so in summary we've talked about uh the
happy path
about keeping your operating system and
uh browser up to date
supporting multiple versions of r by
building r from source
making sure that you have easy access to
our packages
installing products as root and using a
supported operating system
we also talked about recipes and
checklists the crawl walk run strategy
and using the sandbox as well as our
studio connect
our rstudio quickstart
um again reach out to us please please
talk to solutions engineering we'd love
to hear from you
and then at the end here we have the
number of references for you to like go
get some more information
about this i know this was very
reference heavy
but i hope that it was useful to you
we'll be publishing some more material
like this to help your teams
scale out their their products
not just our studio server pro or our
studio connect alone but all of the
products um
together i i think we'll be providing
more
um resources around that approach and
again if um
you do have any issues please look us up
on community and
share your feedback with us we'd love to
hear from you what is the best way to
dig into the
r files that have been hosted on the
rstudio
quick start connect
um yeah so
there are a number of files on the quick
start so
that's actually an interesting question
the easiest way for you to get the r
files is to come into
this view and click on
source versions and click this
and then download the bundle this bundle
will contain
a description of the environment as well
as all the code that's required
to make this run
all right you showed how to deploy api
and shiny apps based on
r how does it work when several
customers
call the service at the same time you
had pods
you managed to have them call in i want
to make sure i understand the question
when you're deploying so when you deploy
a shiny app or an api our studio server
pro
is going to create a bundle
and ship that over to our studio connect
so our studio connect can handle
multiple
bundles simultaneously right so it can
handle all these bundles coming into it
and then when it rebuilds that
application
it's going to build um it's going to
create a container
inside of our studio connect to run that
application so every bundle is going to
get a different
container and that's what you can kind
of see here
with uh the source versions let me pull
up the
other one where's the documents
if i come here you can see like
you can see different versions of this
bundle being pulled up
right so this is one version this is
another version and if you have
you know multiple assets then i'll have
multiple histories
can this setup be done in aws as well
i'm not sure what that means by this
setup but all of our tools can be done
it can be built on-prem or in the cloud
and this exact setup that you're looking
at at quick start
um would be done in aws how does storage
work between local and kubernetes
um so you have to so so we're going to
do another webinar
about deployments and how to how
deployments work at our studio and
you know what the best strategies are
for doing deployments
uh right now that your uh deployments
are being handled kind of
on the back end you know for you um
you know you're not seeing a lot of that
work like when you push a button and you
deploy an application or when you start
up a container
and uh it just automatically runs for
you you're not seeing the deployment
process
but what's happening there is the same
thing every time you
you create an environment you describe
the environment
that you're developing in you bundle up
the code and you ship it over and then
you
reconstitute that environment in the new
location that's just how deployments
work so those three processes are
going to carry over um every time you're
you're creating a container
so the question is how does data storage
work well you can bundle you can like
try to ship over you know that that
information
you know through environment variables
or something like that or you can um
you know reattach that information
through shared file storages so
it's shared file storage
all right can r studio server pro run
docker r instances so
r studio server pro today
does not run docker r instances that's
the short answer
in the future we'll have the ability to
launch
jobs using
different container systems let's see
and that's
again that that's i would encourage you
go back to the blog
that was blog post that was written um
last week
um that will give you more information
about how that works
does the plumber api need end users
to have r um
yeah so no no so the end users on a
plumber api are just
making a web call just like um you're
calling out to a web page
that's the beauty of the api is the r
process is actually hosted on the
rstudio connect
so say you have a scoring equation that
you want to run against
like a database your database could
actually be configured to call out to
rstudio connect
send it the information that needs to
score that model
an r would run on the connect and like
deliver the score based on whatever
complex
analytic model that you've created in r
and then send it back to that system
without that system ever having to use r
that's that's the beauty of the apis
what's the best practice to deploy our
studio connect from dev to prod
environment
yeah that's another really really good
question and i didn't get a chance to
address it here but
um there are ways um
to set up i mean well first of all i
will say
generally that your dev environment is
your rstudio ide
and so um you're wondering like how do
you
deploy it to a production system there's
the push button model that i showed you
but there's also these programmatic
deployment functions that allow you to
share your or publish your work without
on systems that don't have any
information about
um are and that's useful for like
publishing from like github for example
or from some other you know automated
system that your organization uses
those are all really good and there's
information about that on
uh solutions so if i come back here to
solutions and you look at deployments
you can find out more information about
deployments here
where where linux systems have shared
home directories for users what are the
best practices for running
multiple rstudio pro servers so
that's that's exactly right you're
you're going to want
you're going to want to mount your
shared nfs across
all of your servers and there's two
locations i shared it briefly um
but i'll go into more depth uh one is
for your project files
you'll want to share all of your you'll
want to put all your project files on
the nfs
server and the other one is for your
home directory which has some
configuration
knobs inside of it for our studio server
pro both of those should be
mounted across all of your your servers
you can think of your
rstudio servers as compute engines
mostly right they
ingest information into ram and they
operate on it and they spit things back
they don't contain data long term and
that goes with connect as well connects
more of a compute
engine all of your content should be on
a shared file system
all of your metadata should be stored
somewhere else so it's not on those
those compute nodes i hope that made
sense
uh let's see what else do we have
are you able to install an older older
version of
packages when package manager
i think that's package manager question
and yes you can
organize those packages any way that you
would like
can you explain air gapped environments
for package manager so emilio i i take
it that you you haven't
had to deal with that because if you did
um that would be a painful question
air gap environments are are set up for
security purposes and
those servers don't have any connection
to the internet at all
so the only way you can get information
into those is through another process
like some sort of file copy process that
the admins control
so an air gap environment means that if
you want to get the latest
information you can't download it you
have to go talk to somebody else to have
it
transferred over into your setup if you
ever had a
old you know macintosh circa 1985
that would be an air-gapped environment
okay
um could you comment on why building are
from source is better than say
installing it from debian or
a bunch of packages yeah uh so building
r from source is better because
it builds against your
your own system so you're going to be
confident that it will run
with your system so when you compile it
it's using the libraries
on your system um it also you know like
i said it allows you to
put um r you know side by side
with other installations of r so it
becomes extremely useful
but i think best practices in general
involve compiling that that software on
your system
uh what we tend to use uh the repository
you could
what we tend to use for repositories for
is like identifying the dependencies
so when you build r you have to go out
and find all the
things that are needed to build are
and that can be useful uh
the repositories can be very very useful
for that but actually getting the
binaries from the repositories i
i try to steer clear from that all right
so any other things here
systemwide libraries versus user
installed yeah that's
that information so matt that
information is coming um
like there's a lot of work that we're
doing right now when it comes to
library and package uh library
management uh making things reproducible
so your question is a really good one
you know how do you handle
libraries you know system-wide libraries
versus user installed libraries
traditionally the system admin has
control of your system library
and then your users have control of your
user libraries
and that's kind of what we that tends to
be what we recommend today
um that's kind of the state you know the
the de facto standard
i think in the future we'll have better
organization around uh libraries
and how they interact with projects so
that uh things become
more reproducible
[Music]